bread's it now that the UK has
officially notified the European Council
of its intention to leave what's next
the next steps were agreed by all member
states years ago and are set out in
article 50 of the EU treaty the other 27
leaders of the European Council adopt
guidelines for negotiations with the UK
those guidelines can be amended
throughout for negotiation The ministers
in the Council of the EU also meeting in
an EU 27 former authorized the opening
of negotiations they appoint the
Commission as the EU negotiator and
adoption go see aging directives on
behalf of the eu-27 the Commission
negotiates with the UK reporting back to
the leaders in the European Council and
the ministers in the council the
European Parliament is closely and
regularly informed for as long as the UK
remains a member of the EU it
participates in all European Council and
council meetings except when Briggs's is
discussed after the end of negotiations
the consent of the european parliament
is required the deal is then ready to be
concluded by the council when the
agreements entered into force the UK is
no longer an EU member and the EU
treaties cease to apply to it find out
more on the council website